I'm Bear Grylls and this is a wired auto
complete interview
you ready
grills this cameraman the answer is
there are a few of them an incredible
team our crew unsung heroes they're
amazing work incredibly hard carry all
the heavy gear do everything I do but
backwards whilst filming many of those
guys were there at the beginning still
there now brothers be through so much
together I love those guys yeah who did
Bear Grylls climb Everest with we took a
small team of Four soldiers two of us
got to reach the top we had four
fatalities of other climbers who are
with us up there at the time the guy
Arisha top with was a best friend served
beside me in the in the British Special
Forces another unsung hero in my life
called Neil Norton still best friend to
this day I love that what was Bear
Grylls childhood like kind of fun I grew
up on a little island off the south
coast of the UK as I say my dad taught
me to climb at a young age I love those
Early Adventures with him my dad's no
longer alive now but I look back on
those times with like real gratitude
really you know he taught me so much to
the importance which was follow your
dreams look after your friends along the
way have a resilient never give out
Spirit improvise adapt overcome that was
from him whereas Bear Grylls's Festival
yeah we have a festival in the UK it's
called gone wild super fun family
adventure Festival everything from ax
throwing to climbing to survival stuff
mud runs to great music great bands
we've run it for a few years in the UK
now for veteran Charities gone wild look
out for it coming to stay soon okay
how is Bear Grylls still alive by the
grace of God and a great team quite a
lot of luck along the way as well but
nowadays we really try and be smart you
know it's we're in the business of
keeping people alive especially with
running wild where we're taking real
iconic
big old Superstars away you've got to
get it right in the wild you only get it
wrong once there's always risk in the
outdoors and in the in the wild places
and you're dealing with rookies and big
rivers and big mountains hello
survive Bear Grylls gotta have a plan I
know it sounds obvious but so many
people go onto Adventures without a plan
of when things go wrong what happens if
they lose their cell phone or their
battery dies or yeah they're out of
water or somebody gets injured be
prepare for the specific Adventure have
the right gear the right training for
when it goes wrong because as they say
Adventure only really happens
when things go wrong so how to survive
Bear Grylls talk quietly dig deep when
you need to be resourceful
and never give up
any languages does Bear Grylls know a
few are none very well I actually study
Spanish at University and four years of
studying Spanish taught me that my
Spanish is really bad I'm not a natural
linguist in any way I've had to learn
sort of basic I call it survival
Linguistics which way you know North and
it's got me out of a few scrapes for
sure
how did Bear Grylls
understand modi's Hindi when I took the
prime minister of India away you see him
speaking Hindi me replying in English
and then I'm kind of nodding away as
he's speaking but I've got a
simultaneous translation going on in my
ear but it's always a little bit behind
so it kind of looks a little bit weird
like I'm nodding at weird places and the
whole thing is a little weird sink it
was hard because it was raining as well
the earpiece was really cracky so it's
like static in the air but we figured it
out and he speaks actually pretty good
English my Hindi is not very good how
long was Bear Grylls in the military I
spent four years in the military from
the age of 19 to 23. I got to spend
three of my years there with the British
Special Forces where I got so much to
the survival training as well and made
friends that endure to this day
it's Bear Grylls running wild reels it's
a baby of mine that that you know
running wild and I think the Testament
to it is always the sort of starts we
attract and the people who want to come
on the adventures is it real it is real
and uh and I think that's a heart of all
Adventure campaign girls we trusted I
hope so you know I've made mistakes in
my life for sure done bad things in my
life for sure but I hope I'm trustworthy
they're trying to be trustworthy so Will
Ferrell Bear Grylls episode Will Ferrell
was the first Adventure Show I did with
someone else it was the first one where
we took big Hollywood star away we
pushed them really hard probably too
hard still to this day if I see will he
goes oh my God that Journey that was a
bull Buster you know will on that
episode was incredible actually you know
we were right at tip end of the Arctic
tough conditions he was in at a deep end
in every way he never gave up kept
smiling most of the time and I think if
we'd kept running wild of that intensity
we'd never have had a season two so we
keep them fast keep them a million miles
an hour but make them achievable you
know we're not there to break anyone
we're there to build people and that's
definitely become the DNA of the show
over the years
what has Bear Grylls achieved what have
I achieved good family three great Boys
Still Married to the girl I met when I
was 22. good friends
still smiling still going still doing
what I love I never take that for
granted what island is Bear Grylls film
done we live on a little island off the
Welsh Coast in the UK and we've owned it
for for years now our boys have been
brought up there off grid about two
miles offshore one little house wild
place to get on and off the island we
have a little rigid inflatable boat
offshore craft that we just bomb back
and forth to the mainland in getting
supplies is always a bit of a mission
but uh also kind of fun what does Bear
Grylls eat at home sorry to disappoint
it's not all tarantulas scorpions snakes
and rat brain a lot of red meat a lot of
liver a lot of eggs a lot of fruit a lot
of honey try and stay away from the junk
stuff as much as we can the processed
food eat like our ancestors grow in a
little bit of wilderness food every now
and again just to keep everyone on their
toes what has been is eaten had a good
breakfast a lot of great yogurt in Honey
some fruit coffee bit of juice ready to
go what accent does Bear Grylls have I
don't know I get British I guess
sometimes people go are you Australian
obviously that takes a great compliment
because we love Australia even though we
do beat them often in the rugby so yeah
where did Bear Grylls
get his name you know it's Chris and
Edward my sister then said that was such
a boring name she called me Teddy Teddy
Bear I don't know as a kid I didn't
really like it I always wanted a normal
name but actually I looked that now and
it could have been way worse where has
Bear Grylls traveled to an occupational
hazard of my job is that we do travel a
lot done a lot in Wyoming for running
wild Scotland for a couple of trips and
jungles Costa Rica Central America some
mountains in the Alps in Europe
home in Wales little island in the UK
good places when did Bear Grylls meet
president zielinski yeah a few months
ago I got to travel to Ukraine to spend
time with him walk around the city a
little bit hear a little bit about his
background his life growing up for a
show called Warzone real privilege for
me to do that was a special one
start his career I don't know I never
really got to think of it as a career I
suppose the answer is I started that
a life of adventure when I was a kid
with my dad former Marine climber taught
me a lot of this stuff when I was a
young boy but in terms of TV stuff I
suppose started at age about 26 somebody
approached me from Discovery Channel and
said could we do a show where we drop
you in difficult places you show us how
to get out of there a privilege so
that's that one
Bear Grylls
sting I was stung by a bunch of African
bees ones trying to get some honey out
of a nest and I think the lesson is in
the Wilds it's not always the big things
they're going to get you it's often the
little stuff mosquitoes some angry bees
my face ballooned up my family said
actually Bear is an improvement Bear
Grylls
jellyfish sting I think this is probably
about a running wild episode with Mel B
from the Spice Girls and I got stung by
jellyfish and she ended up peeing on my
hand I think actually I've learned over
the years the advice actually is tenuous
I'm not sure P actually does very much
apart from sterilize it a little bit and
she was adamant who was going to work
Bear Grylls healthy feel pretty good
feel fit and strong we have a great
outdoor Fitness Company it's veteran run
called be military fit so I train with
that Community most days just Sean sharp
half an hour I consider it is part of my
job I've got to try and be strong and as
healthy as I can
work in progress always why is Bear
Grylls oh dear here we go
oh that's nice inspirational I've
learned in life you can only try and
live from this and try and follow this
and try and speak from this share the
struggles share the doubts the failures
as much as the successes and the wins in
life know the value of great friends try
and keep the rest of it simple
that is all the boards thank you for
lovely questions and for all of you guys
watching keep going respect for all your
adventures courage kindness never give
up we got it team